hey youtubers it's Charlie so we got a
bunch of thor ragnarok stuff that was
confirmed and Marvel just announced
their Comic Con plans and it is nuts so
I'll talk about the Thor stuff first
then I'll talk about Marvel comic con
the spider-man giveaway still going on
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
Kevin Feige actually has this cool quote
about Ragnarok where he says I think
that we are finding ourselves as we
complete phase 3 and finish this 22
movie narrative talking about all the
Marvel movies up to now that is working
out that way we did three Iron Man films
three Captain America films three Thor
films things change drastically in
Ragnarok and then build directly into
infinity war so that implies a lot of
fan o stuff which I'll talk about later
because in the grand tradition of things
they're mixing and matching a lot of
elements from the classic comics so the
big thing is that they finally confirm
that Surtur is going to be in Ragnarok
now thank God for toys last year at
Comic Con they showed off some concept
footage it seemed like he appeared Hulk
was punching him so Hulk vs. Fire Lord
surgery but it was sort of concept
footage so it didn't look like the last
Thor trailer that we got a little while
ago so I'm expecting when we see him
again it'll be full see gene he'll
actually look really badass but no idea
they're going to put him in any of the
trailers because he's a pretty big deal
there are a lot of things in that comic
con concept footage that we haven't seen
yet like been worse wolf we still
haven't seen him in one of the trailers
but there been a lot of different ways
that he's been used in the comics in the
Ragnarok of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is a little bit different from
Jack Kirby's Ragnarok during which Loki
was a much bigger part of bringing that
about we've already talked about how
there's a lot of Jack Kirby all over
Ragnarok mostly visual influences
because it looks like the Eternals and
the Celestials are sitting in the
background of this shot with the Grand
Master's he's watching Thor fight in the
arena with the Hulk Buttrey watching the
trailer knowing that sorters in the
movie you now wonder if he's responsible
for some of the destructions that you
see his origin and how he came to be
trapped in his realm moose full-time is
actually the origin of the odinforce
it's a really cool story he exists on
the lowest level of the world tree right
here adjacent to Niffleheim which is
where he'll is where hella has been trap
now the Marvel Cinematic Universe might
change this a little bit but there's a
lot of parallels for Christian mythology
where Lucifer revolts against heaven God
banishes him to hell to be the devil and
reign over that realm and watch over
those souls for all eternity mooseville
Haman the fire demons are even worse
their destruction incarnate so it sounds
like hell is responsible for breaking
the enchantment that traps them their
inserter is the one that lays waste to a
scart here bringing about the beginning
of Ragnarok now Ragnarok is a much
bigger cosmic concept but you saw during
Thor the dark world when they were
trying to align the nine realms you saw
a brief look at moose bow hain here the
really cool thing about Serdar is that
he also leads to the origin of the
odinforce so Odin is flashing back to
the adventure where he traps Serdar in
Moose Bo hain where his brothers Billy
and bay were still alive they go there
searching to explore the nine realms and
learn all that is so they talked to
Serdar and asked him if the prophecy is
true will you eventually destroy Asgard
and Surtur explains to them that he will
destroy Asgard using Twilight the sword
of doom in the eternal blame so Odin
says to him hard pass wouldn't it be
better if we broke your sword and took
the flame back in so many words in the
grand Shakespeare way that they speak in
the Thor movies he says better try
so Onan is his brothers try to take him
down his brothers end up dying but he
takes their life force and absorbs it
that becomes the odinforce so as I'm
posting this video right now in one week
we're going to have d23 the week after
that is Comic Con so in addition to Thor
Ragnarok being their next big movie that
they'll be promoting at Comic Con
there's just a bunch of stuff that's
going to be happening around that movie
in infinity war in the next couple of
weeks so what's probably going to happen
is they will screen brand-new footage
from infinity war as well as Ragnarok as
a d23 presentation but almost every year
that they do d23 they do not release any
of that footage so that includes Star
Wars stuff too they'll be showing off
episode 8 footage they're in they're not
coming to Comic Con so that's separate
Star Wars stuff I'll talk about in a
different video depending on what it is
that they show
so whatever ends up happening next
weekend I will totally do a video for
new footage but just be prepared for
them to not drop that online on to the
big show though I know the thing you
guys really want to know about is what's
happening at comic-con Marvel just
dropped a bomb they are going to close
out Comic Con with a two-hour panel now
they say it's 90 minutes so this
probably is going to be breaks in
between big presentations it's like two
hours of time but really it's 90 minutes
of actual presentation so that means
they're showing off loads of footage
from a bunch of different phase 3 movies
including infinity war which I'll talk
about in a second but also in addition
to that they're probably filling some of
that time with a live show like they did
with Loki so some special real-life
presentation in addition to all the
footage they're showing off they've
already confirmed there's going to be
Thor Ragnarok Black Panther infinity war
in an ant-man and the wasp but obviously
they haven't started shooting ant-man in
the wasp so that'll only be concept
footage I don't think any that's going
to make it online
the first genuine infinity war trailer
isn't supposed to drop till this fall
when thor ragnarok hits theaters so they
might not release the infinity war Comic
Con footage online I'll still do a video
breakdown of it even if they don't post
it online so don't worry about that
but I do think there's a really good
chance that the new thor ragnarok and
black panther trailers will drop online
just because we're due for some new
footage and that's coming up so soon
that means that we have flash we have
infinity war Thor Ragnarok black panther
there's so many things that are
happening on Saturday so I'll do another
Comic Con schedule video where I explain
all the videos that I'm going to do I
have a pretty good idea of what's going
to be happening each day there's way too
many things for me to get everything so
I'll probably just be prioritizing
videos based on footage that drops like
Justice League is dropping their next
trailer Saturday morning so what will
happen is is the week before Comic Con
I'll just remind everybody to click the
bell turn alerts on for videos that I
post so you don't miss anything because
they'll be like 10 to 12 videos
throughout comic-con between Wednesday
I'll make a special video playlist that
I'll pin at the top of my channel so if
you just come to YouTube / emergency
awesome you'll see the playlist so don't
worry it's going to be freaking crazy
I'll remind everybody the week before
everything happens
what's happening when it's going to drop
it'll be great so because there's so
many big things that they haven't
revealed about thor ragnarok especially
with Thanos the infinity gems I think
we'll see a little more in the next
trailer but I don't expect them to
outright reveal Thanos or infinity gems
in any of that footage they only show up
a little bit more in Hall H than they
reveal publicly so I wouldn't be
surprised that they show off vanos in
that Hall H footage but you have all the
infinity war stuff happening they'll at
least show off a concept teaser so
they'll probably be a little bit of
footage to bridge the gap between
Ragnarok and what's happening during
infinity war because even though black
panther is the last movie before
infinity war Thor is the last big cosmic
place that we're going to see that in
the last place that we'll see the final
infinity gem there's been all kinds of
speculation about how hella is going to
show up during infinity war and sort of
be the stand-in for the cosmic entity
death during the original Infinity
Gauntlet storyline we can speculate on
that but Kate Blanchet is such a
fantastic actor that they're probably
going to do everything they can to keep
her active in the Marvel Universe even
if they don't do more Thor movies after
Ragnarok but there'll be a bunch more
Comic Con videos over the next week just
leave all your requests in the comments
below there's going to be some new flash
DC TV later tonight they just confirmed
a big Smallville character is coming
into the DC TV universe again
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Elaine Chung please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything click here for
spider-man homecoming post-credits and
click here to learn about the game of
Thrones episodes that are dropping next
week thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight